we have a clip here from uh ted last so
i want to show this
do you want to set it up in any way or
do you want you want help with this sure
i i believe it's from uh our fifth
episode so yeah uh ted
is um his wife and kid are coming over
to uh to visit
and so he's just talking to his boss um
which is the character rebecca welton
played by hannah wattingham
uh deftly she's great great yeah you
know she's
did you watch game of thrones yeah yeah
you know she's the gal
the shame the nun shame no there she is
isn't that great with the [ __ ] that's i
didn't know that yeah that's fine
i didn't know that because we're like
the only couple that didn't watch game
of thrones
so when when she came in for the
audition and i was like oh she's
fantastic what else has she done
and people are like oh she's this and i
know it just as like a gif
i know that character is a gift but yeah
you know she looks completely different
uh as any of us can do with the yeah she
is your uh
she owns the team and she has hired you
and we find out more about why she hired
you but uh
it's you guys are terrific culture clash
throughout yes
so that's what this scene is let's take
this uh take a look at this clip from
ted lasso
good morning ted hey
i mean it's my fault for staring at my
phone
i just can't stop checking on my
family's flight you know i haven't
shared this with too many folks but um
michelle and i we've been having some
marital issues ted
you really don't have to talk about this
if you don't want to i don't mind
tried couples therapy didn't like the
other couple though
oh it feels good to laugh yeah you know
our therapist gave us this code word to
use so if either of us says oklahoma
the other one has to tell the god's
honest truth yeah you know it's pretty
helpful
did ruin the musical for me though so
now every time i hear oh what a
beautiful morning or uh what sorry with
the fringe on top
or chubby dumps no it's from king and i
anyway if i hear any of those tunes i
immediately think about my wife telling
me that my constant optimism is
too much and we're back there we go
see how i did that it was amazing just a
little head a little head moving you dip
right back into it
yeah um no seriously uh i
i cannot uh more strongly suggest a
television show right now because it
really is
it's uplifting it's really funny and uh
sweet
and uh i really think people are gonna
love it uh who haven't seen it yet
new episodes of ted lasso are available
every friday on apple tv plus
so uh i'm really looking forward to
because and i'm i'm hooked so
yeah we i want you to go make more right
now in your backyard
i i i can shoot little things you know
it'll be a little sloppy
um but uh you know and he'll he'll be on
a bender
ted will be on a bender because he's got
his beard but you know thank you so much
for doing this i really appreciate it
no of course thanks for having me as
always it's always great to see and chat
with you